particularly at MIT but in other places
teamwork is critical to academic success
one of the things I tell freshmen is
that you know I have been teaching at
MIT now for a long time and the students
are wonderful and very bright but what
I've noticed is that every year I see
two or three students really stand out
you know after they graduate and go on
and do big things and I see this earring
a year off and all of the students are
wonderful they're academically gifted
and they're highly motivated they have
fire in their belly ok so what's the
difference between those two versus the
rest well one day I figured it out the
the two who go on to do big things have
learned to work with others that's it
nothing else that I could see they have
learned to work not only with people
they they share interests but also with
people that they don't necessarily share
interests that's the trick it's easy to
work with people that you know who are
like you it's harder to work with people
who are not like you but when you learn
to do to be able to work across the
spectrum of people then you can
basically tap their gifts that's what
entrepreneurship is actually and so this
is a little spiel that I give them as
part of why I have in my syllabus a goal
for this course is to learn to work in
teams I think I have that in every class
I teach it doesn't matter what class I
said a goal of this class is for you to
learn to work in teams